Welcome to this video.
This is the second video on examples.
In this case, we are going to be
querying to layer data within a landscape.
Just a quick example of how you can use that to generate your PCG.
Here we are, and we are on slide 2,
example 2, painting PCGs.
In this, we're going to see a very simple,
straightforward square of a landscape.
What's interesting about this landscape is,
it's creating the grass,
but it's only creating the grass where
we are using a landscape layer of grass.
To demonstrate this, if I was to come into
the selection mode for landscape,
let's expand this out a little bit.
Now, you'll see that I'm on the paint tab here across
the top and I've already loaded in
my landscape material and it has two layers in it,
grass and mud.
At the moment, it is all set to grass.
What I'm going to do is,
I'm going to change over to the mud layer,
and I'm just going to paint on some mud.
You'll see the PCG is now
populating some stones based on that layer.
It's reading it into the landscape material,
and I can design my landscape and
my PCG just by painting it into the world.
That's how we do it.
Let's see how this was put together.
The first thing is we need a landscape material,
which is set to this.
Here we have in our landscape material,
important part is our landscape layer blend,
going into our material outlet,
our material attributes, and we have two.
We have a grass layer and we have a mud.
This is going to dictate what material is on the land.
Now, if we look into our PCG graph,
we have a very simple, straightforward PCG graph.
We are getting the landscape data as before,
and we're coming in and transforming the points.
But what is quite interesting,
I'll see if I can get it up here as a debug object.
If I was to click OK,
let's have a look, you can see that at the end here,
we have an extra attribute which is
automatically getting added to our points attributes.
That is the grass and the mud layer.
What these are is they give us
a variable of how much that layer is painted.
You can see at some points it's halfway between the two.
Most is over one or zero.
That is what I am filtering on here.
If I look at this filter attribute element,
I'm looking at the attribute grass,
that's going to be this grass attribute here saying,
is it more than,
and I'm doing a constant threshold of zero.
Those are the elements that you need to change.
I'm doing exactly the same here for the mud.
I'm just changing the mud over,
and I've changed over what meshes we are smalling.
But it's just an example of
how a lot of different stuff gets placed into attributes.
As soon as there is an attribute,
you can sit there and use them and filter by them.
That's all you need to do.
Obviously, it can get vastly more complicated,
but it just demonstrates quickly
how you can get more data into your PCG
to change the way it works.